wie bitte ja es stimmt tatsächlich in
los angeles werden jetzt die straßen
weiß gestrichen um das hitzeproblem der
stadt ein zudem ob das klappen wird und
noch viele weitere kreative und kuriose
klima rettende projekte gibt es jetzt
hier bei den science fiction herzlich
willkommen
wir reden ja hier immer wieder mal über
den klimawandel und seine folgen
natürlich ist es längst überfällig dass
jeder einzelne mithilft die globale
menschengemachte erwärmung zu stoppen
oder zumindest zu verlangsamen und wenn
wir mal ehrlich sind ist das doch im
alltag echt leicht umzusetzen fahrrad
oder zumindest bus fahren oder bahn
fahren statt das auto zu benutzen zum
beispiel im großen stil müssten die
erneuerbaren energie gefördert werden
und so weiter und so fort einige von
euch können diese ganzen dinge zum klima
retten aber vielleicht nicht mehr hören
ja da verstehe ich aber ich habe jetzt
was für euch denn forschungsteams
weltweit haben auch noch andere wirklich
sehr ausgefallene und kuriose ideen um
den klimawandel zu stoppen
die top-vier abgefahrensten ideen gegen
den klimawandel jetzt bei klicks und
science fiction auf der vier weiße
straßen und städte die erste idee kommt
aus den usa
der aktuelle präsident donald trump hat
ja mal gesagt der klimawandel sei eine
erfindung der chinesen wir wissen alle
dass er nicht wirklich ein vorreiter in
sachen klimapolitik ist andere
amerikanische politiker dafür aber umso
mehr sie wollen die klimaziele wie
geplant umsetzen so zum beispiel los
angeles die stadt hat ein riesiges
hitzeproblem temperaturen von mehr als
35 grad sind genauso wie hitze tote
keine seltenheit der bürgermeister von
los angeles kurz abgekürzt hat deswegen
jetzt eine maßnahme gegen den
klimawandel beschlossen die auf den
ersten blick erstmal ziemlich kurios
klingt einige straßen der stadt werden
mit einem hellen kühlen belag
asphaltiert das komplette stadtbild von
los angeles wird sich dadurch verändern
konkret wird eine spezialfarbe zum
einsatz kommen die in der lage ist den
asphalt um 7 grad herunterzukühlen
ursprünglich entwickelt wurde diese
falle namens cool ziel militärfahrzeugen
die dadurch während ihrer wartezeiten
heruntergekühlt werden konnten
dadurch waren sie besser getarnt und
konnten auch durch infrarot kameras
nicht vom feind entdeckt werden und kohl
ziel soll nicht nur die straßen abkühlen
sondern auch einen anderen positiven
effekt mit sich bringen auch die
klimaanlagen sollen dadurch weniger
laufen eine kuriose aber effektive idee
im herbst wird die farbe nun in einigen
bezirken der stadt getestet mal sehen ob
es sich durchsetzen
dennoch ist das ein wirklich teures
projekt pro kilometer straße kostet das
ganze rund 40.000 dollar weiter gedacht
könnte es aber zukünftig ganze städte in
weiß oder hellen farben wie beige geben
nicht nur weiße straßen sondern auch
weiße dächer und häuser sie würden das
sonnenlicht dann ins all reflektieren
ganz nach dem vorbild vieler dörfer in
nordafrika oder südeuropa deren häuser
selbst bei der größten hitze kühl bleibt
die drei künstlicher vulkan ausbruch
schwefel wolken in der atmosphäre
wir haben hier ja schon öfter darüber
berichtet heftige vulkanausbrüche können
letztendlich dafür sorgen dass sich der
himmel verdunkelt viele millionen tonnen
schwefel werden bei einem ausbruch in
die atmosphäre geschleudert 17 millionen
tonnen waren es zum beispiel beim
ausbruch des pinatubo auf den
philippinen im jahr 1991 auch damals
verdunkelten die kleinen schwefelsäure
tröpfchen in der atmosphäre den himmel
die temperatur damals sank weltweit um
0,5 grad es gibt tatsächlich
überlegungen solch einen ausbruch
künstlich nachzuahmen
diese ideen kommen aus dem bereich des
sogenannten geoengineering oder auch
climate engineering genannt damit sind
gezielte eingriffe in das weltweite
klimageschehen gemeint also grob gesagt
mit hightech gegen den klimawandel
denn wenn schwefeldioxid im großen
maßstab in die stratosphäre gesprüht
wird gebe es wohl einen ähnlichen effekt
wie bei einem großen vulkanausbruch das
sonnenlicht würde durch die
schwefelpartikel ins weltall reflektiert
auf der erde würde es kühler werden eine
ähnliche idee kommt von einem chemie
nobelpreisträger demnach sollen
spezialflugzeuge oder heißluftballons in
einer höhe von 15 bis 20 kilometern
feine schwefelpartikel versprühen seiner
rechnung nach ließe sich die temperatur
auf der erde dadurch um bis zu 25 grad
bis zum jahr 2100 senken und diese idee
war nicht ganz neu den schon in den 80er
jahren gab es ein klimaforscher der auch
schwefeldioxid als lösungsvorschlag im
kampf gegen den klimawandel
vorgeschlagen hatte doch die nachteile
sind gravierend denn der schwefel in der
atmosphäre
würde wohl nicht nur das klima abkühlen
er würde auch die ozonschicht zerstören
forschungsteams weltweit denken deshalb
jetzt über andere aerosole nach mit
denen solche ideen umsetzbar werden und
auf der zwei sonnenschirme im weltall
ganz ohne chemie kommt sie die idee
eines astronomenteams der university of
arizona aus auch sie beschäftigen sich
mit dem geo engineering und wollen den
klimawandel auf der erde bekämpfen indem
sie zwischen der sonne und der erde zu
etwas ausspannen wie einen gigantischen
sonnenschirm konkret schlagen sie
siliziumscheiben vor die die
einstrahlung der sonne um knapp zwei
prozent reduzieren sollen 16 millionen
dünne siliziumscheiben müssten davon mit
hilfe elektromagnetischer kanonen ins
all geschossen werden an dem punkt wo
sich die anziehungskraft von erde und
sonne aufhebt da würden sie sich dann
auf rein und eine art sonnensegel bilden
doch diese idee steckt noch in den
kinderschuhen zum einen wäre das
natürlich mit gigantischen kosten
verbunden zum anderen sind die risiken
abzuwägen modellrechnung sagen voraus
dass sich die tropen solch ein projekt
abkühlen könnten arktis und antarktis
könnten dagegen trotzdem wärmer werden
und auf der einst künstliche bäume
pflanzen mit bäumen das klima retten das
prinzip dahinter hat sich ja jeder schon
einmal gehört wälder nehmen über die
bäume kohlendioxid aus der luft auf sie
fixieren es im holz so sinkt der co2
gehalt in der atmosphäre und die
erderwärmung wird gebremst und so heißt
es immer wieder das große flächen
aufgeforstet werden müssen doch der
nachteil liegt auf der hand es sind
immense flächen die gebraucht würden und
zudem würde es jahrzehnte dauern bis es
etwas nutzt deswegen gibt es im kontext
geoengineering auch allerhand ideen
künstliche bäume zu pflanzen bäume aus
stein könnten beispielsweise nach dem
sogenannten er capture verfahren co2 aus
der atmosphäre holen das co2 würde
hierbei unterirdisch gelagert werden
doch die technik ist teuer und noch
nicht wirklich effektiv dennoch ist es
ziemlich aufwendig das co2 aus der
atmosphäre zu holen ja das waren jetzt
also die top-vier kuriosen ideen zum
kampf gegen den klimawandel
doch was das geo-engineering betrifft da
halten es die meisten
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissen
und auch regierungschef dieser erde für
zu früh solche technik tatsächlich
umzusetzen
sie seien zu wenig erforscht und die
auswirkungen zu krass dennoch steht auch
fest dass solche ideen nicht gleich von
vornherein als mittel gegen die
schlimmsten folgen der globalen
erwärmung auszuschließen sind ja und
hier bei pixum halte ich euch natürlich
dazu auf dem laufenden wenn ihr kein
video zum thema und auch zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann
drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergesst nicht den genau auf die glocke
ja hier geht es weiter mit klimawandel
bewiesen skeptiker endgültig widerlegt
ja sehr spannendes video mit allen
wichtigen argumenten also nicht
verpassen und draufklicken und ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran